parmigiano
to
foreign
we already know this
oliva
today we will
wait what we are cooking so we will have
to use
what's
is the kind of rice so this
rice is actually grown in italy in the
northern part of italy
an area that's called the
that's crossed by the longest river
in italy this river has a very short
name usually we have very long words but
this river
is the longest and it's called
so
so the river pop brings a lot of water
in the paddan plain de la tianura padana
there we grow different varieties of
rice
including risot arborio
is very good to make risotto
because it stays hard at the same time
it releases a nice cream
so you will see that it's different if
you try to make risotto
with a different rice you will not get
the same result
these are our friends
usually when we cook
for everything always we will make four
different varieties
so we will make risotto
who knows
this is actually directly from italy
because this is already the second class
we can read the articles
the determinant determinative article lo
blo ferano
that's a specific variety they're not so
easy to find here
so just went for whatever i found at the
supermarket
sliced shiitake i think it will be
equally tasty
then we will make risotto corn
that's a mystery for everybody but we
have two different
articles so he's saying why is
so we have two different articles
masculine
singular that's ill and
i just want you to pay attention to the
pronunciation
you see radicchio we have the c-h-i
in c okay when you have
is
so you see here i made the same trick
that we used before
it would be lo asparago
but lo asparago it sounds weird
get rid of the o we put the sign the
apostrophe
and it becomes
so we will make this asparagi
and then for the meat lovers
so what else is on the table
what else
yes like when you're playing dices you
use dado
you